joe biden believes if he yells at
americans about covet they'll forget
about afghanistan and the biden
administration continues to downplay the
ongoing crisis in afghanistan i'm bench
bureau this is the bench bureau show
show is sponsored by expressvpn i
protect my data with vpn so should you
visit expressvpn.com
ben speaking of which a few decades ago
private citizens used to be largely that
private well what changed the interwebs
think about all the things that you've
browsed search for watched or tweeted
now imagine all of that data being
crawled through collected aggregated by
third parties into a permanent public
record your record and then that stuff
can be used against you it can be
monetized well why not just keep your
data private the way i do by using
express vpn did you know there are
hundreds of data brokers out there and
their only business is to buy and sell
your data and they don't have to tell
you who they're selling it to or get
your consent one of those data points is
your ip address data harvesters can use
your ip to uniquely identify you and
your location but with expressvpn my
connection gets rerouted through an
encrypted server my ip address is masked
every time i turn expressvpn on i'm
given a random ip address shared by
other expressvpn customers which makes
it really tough for third parties to
identify me and harvest my data the best
part it's really easy to use you can
download expressvpn with one click of a
button and then you can start using it
with another click of a button and now
you're done so if like me you believe
your data is your business head on over
to
expressvpn.com today and get three extra
months for free that's exp
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
ben go to expressvpn.com
ben to learn more alrighty so with the
disaster in afghanistan continuing to
unleash itself joe biden has decided it
is time to distract he tried this last
week late last week the president of the
united states had a press conference
about covid and then he also had a press
conference about the build back better
agenda and all of this stuff and
everybody was like well aren't there
like ten to fifteen thousand americans
who are still stuck in afghanistan he's
like i don't wanna talk about that we're
not going to talk about it
and they fell asleep well he's still
trying to do this hey the idea is that
we are going to focus on covid because
he likes talking about covid better than
he likes talking about afghanistan which
by the way does show you what an
unbelievable disaster afghanistan is
because covenant ain't great okay
covenant in the united states right now
is a problem kovat continues to roll out
across the country
the daily case count continues to be in
the hundred thousand range in the united
states the daily death count in the
united states is continuing to rise
right now it's around a thousand a day
800 a day depends on which day you're
looking at it's already started to peak
in a lot of states we'll get to that in
a moment but joe biden would rather talk
about this stuff because he is hopeful
that he can yell at you about covenant
and scare you about covet and get you
back to yelling at ron desantis rather
than talking about the fact that he
precipitously pulled out from
afghanistan leaving the entire country
in the hands of the taliban revivifying
al qaeda revivifying isis and
simultaneously preventing thousands of
americans from leaving he would rather
you not talk about that so you'd rather
talk about covet that's how badly things
are going for the biden administration
at this point they'd rather talk about
the disease he said was going to be over
by july than the disaster is now
unleashed in afghanistan and so let's
talk about what he's saying about kobe
because now his his plan here apparently
is that he's going to just push more and
more restrictive activity and then if
you push back against it he's going to
suggest you want americans to die
because he thinks that he got away with
this with trump last year and so he
thinks he's going to do it again they're
just going to keep running this playbook
until you feel compelled to vote for joe
biden it is that simple he's going to
keep saying that you need to mask up
forever and that you need to keep
getting booster shots forever and that
your kids need to mask up forever and
and if you oppose any of these things if
you say listen i'm vaccinated and if i
infect somebody else and they are
unvaccinated because they chose not to
get vaccinated that really is their
business
and if you say there's no evidence that
kids should be masking at this point
like according to new york magazine no
evidence kids should be masking in
schools if you say that stuff according
to joe biden you're very very very bad
and so yesterday the big news of the day
surrounding covent is that the fda
finally approved the pfizer vaccine now
if you're waiting around on the fda's
full approval of the fisher vaccine let
me just say you're a buffoon and the
reason i say this is because the fda had
already given emergency use
authorization and hundreds of millions
of people around the world had already
taken the physical vaccine we have the
biggest data set in world history with
regard to a vaccine with regard to
pfizer and modern vaccines being rolled
out across hundreds of nations or dozens
of nations at the very least with
hundreds of millions of people having
taken it and with the serious side
effects being extraordinarily low right
that
we know that
the big argument here is not that the
fda shouldn't have approved the vaccine
the question is where the hell were you
guys for the last eight months
i got vaccinated back in february march
my parents same thing last i checked it
is now august it turns out that your
crappy regulatory bureaucracy actually
inhibited people from getting the
vaccine for months and months and months
and months and by the way i really don't
think there are many people who are
waiting around for fda approval to get
the vaccine people who are waiting
around to get the vaccine are not going
to be satisfied by the fda approval and
people who wanted to get the vaccine
already got the vaccine right that's the
that is i think the reality of the
situation so what exactly is the great
importance of the fda giving full use
authorization as opposed to emergency
authorization
on this thing because i mean what
exactly were they gonna do are they
gonna say well you know what no
we gave emergency authorization but no
full use authorization so all you
suckers all you 150 million americans
who already took the vaccine
we're gonna have to suck that out of
your arm we're gonna have to find a way
to get that out of your blood now yeah
good luck to that so this was always
going to get full use authorization
because it should have full use
authorization but it should have
happened like six months ago seven
months ago
okay so what was this really this was
really just an excuse for people on the
left to start calling for mandates to
start politicizing this thing even more
now
here is the thing once you have had the
vaccine the vaccine remained buy all
available data extremely durable against
hospitalization and death from coven 19
including the delta variant it is not as
durable against preventing infection
there can be breakthrough infections
this is true for virtually all vaccines
by the way
they're
i'm not aware of any vaccine where there
are no breakthrough infections so delta
breaks through
sometimes
the the coveted vaccines the pfizer
moderna jnj astrazeneca cova vaccines it
breaks through them but the result of
the breakthrough is like you get a cold
or you get a mild flu which
is in the we don't care about this
category or should be and we don't care
about this category because
when covet first broke out across the
world if everybody had said man there's
a bad flu going around this year that
would just be called the regular year
the problem with kovid is that it was
killing millions of people all over the
world so if it has now been downgraded
to you get a breakthrough infection and
man that's a bad cold no one should care
about that that should not be a question
of public health concern
but the idea is that now that you have
the fda back approved vaccines now we
can start doing vaccine mandates now we
have the excuse to do vaccine mandates
and tell everybody they must get the
vaccine now i've been vaccinated as i
say since i believe early march late
february somewhere in there
and because i'm vaccinated i don't care
whether anyone else around me is
vaccinated i don't care it is your
business in fact i'm sure that i i'm one
of the only people in my office who is
vaccinated and you can ask the folks in
my office literally the the
in about one week after i got the second
vaccine i said to the people in my
office i don't care if you wear masks i
don't care if you vaccinated around me
because i don't care i'm now protected
fine okay but the idea is from joe biden
that we must cuddle everyone into
vaccinating now again i'm very
pro-vaccination i think that if you are
certainly above the age of 18
the the risk factors tend toward covid
as opposed to toward side effects from
the vaccine i think once you get below
the age of 18 there are some serious
questions to be asked about whether the
risks from the vaccine outweigh the
risks from covered once you're under the
age of 12 even the fda won't authorize
that for use under the age of 12. but as
as large as an advocate vaccines as i am
and i'm a huge advocate of vaccines i am
probably the strongest advocate for
vaccination on the right and this has
been true for years and years and years
like going back
well over a decade
despite that i don't think that you
should have to be vaccinated to work as
a construction worker i don't think that
you should be you should have to be
vaccinated in order to work at a hotel i
don't think that that is necessary
because again the vaccine is available
to all adults
and if those adults are particularly
vulnerable they should be wearing an n95
mask
and yet the new york times sort of let
the cat out of the bag yesterday when
they ran an article called with fda
approval pentagon and others add vaccine
requirements
the idea here is that what the fda
approval really was about it was really
not about the the full use authorization
per se because again hundreds of
millions of people have already had the
vaccine the full use authorization was
about creating a leg for people who want
mandates to stand on
within hours of the announcement the
pentagon cvs the state of state
university of new york system and the
new york city school system among others
announced they would enforce mandates
they'd prepared to carry out but had
made contingent on the fda's action one
of the first and largest to move ahead
was the pentagon defense secretary lloyd
austin had already received
authorization from president biden to
mandate vaccines for all active duty
troops once the vaccine was fully
approved and he was moving swiftly to
put the plans into action so the
question is what are the vaccines and
the mandatory vaccines designed to do
and if the idea is that the mandatory
vaccines are designed to prevent
hospitalization and death what you're
really saying is that you have to have
this treatment
in order you have to have this treatment
to stop bad things from happening to you
now normally in a free society
we say that things that you do to
yourself are kind of on you and we don't
say you must do x in order to protect
yourself right that is a pretty rare
thing in public policy so the other case
that was made is that you need to get
vaccinated so you're not passing on the
disease to others but again all adults
now have the capacity to protect
themselves and one of the things that we
have learned over the course of the last
several months is that even if you are
vaccinated there is a chance that you're
going to pass this on to others
which is why of course you have seen the
cdc idiotically recommending that even
after you're vaccinated you need to mask
up with other people who are vaccinated
even though everybody who's vaccinated
is going to get a mild cold or mild flu
statistically speaking nearly everyone
if they get a breakthrough case after
having been vaccinated but again all of
this is just a political excuse to cram
down mandates and then to claim that the
people who oppose the mandates are in
favor of death that's what this is
really about
i know this because they've been playing
this game for the last year if you're
ron desantis and you said let's protect
the elderly and if you're younger and
you're healthier
if you want to wear a mask go ahead and
wear a mask if you don't want to wear a
mask that's on you
but you got to take responsibility for
what risk level you wish to assume in
life
if you're on the santas or if you're the
country of sweden you're bad and you
want death right this is the case that
the left has been making for a very long
time i don't see it ever ending by the
way because i don't see any limiting
principle here
the limiting principle at least at the
beginning was we'll do this until we
have a vaccine and everybody's had the
opportunity to get it
now we have a vaccine everybody in the
united states has had the opportunity to
get the vaccine
so
what are we talking about there is no
limiting principle at this point there's
no second vaccine around the corner
and the evidence on the booster shots by
the way is relatively skimpy and the who
for example does not recommend the
booster shots the who says that the
booster shots may not actually increase
your antibody response
right the who is saying that there that
there are serious questions to be asked
about whether it it actually
prevents hospitalization and death to
take a booster shot and you have the the
bite administration pushing universal
booster shots which is even crazier than
what they've been doing pretty much
everywhere elsewhere right there's some
places like israel where they've been
doing booster shots but they've really
been pushing it on people who are older
and more vulnerable first
in the united states you had the bite
administration the fda recommending
booster shots for everybody the who's
like i don't know where you're getting
any of that
in any case this is all the predicate
it's all the predicate for talking about
why you are bad right this is the case
you are bad if you won't mask your kids
if you won't mask yourself you are bad
so dr anthony fauci the greatest of all
the doctors
the science right he has declared
himself the science so he went on mehdi
hassan's show on msnbc
and he was asked about what kind of mask
you should use
and he gives a completely unscientific
answer because again
for many people masking is not about
protecting yourself it were really about
protecting you you'd wear an n95
it is not about that what has become for
so many people all over the united
states including vaccinated people is
the signal that i am deeply worried the
signal that i deeply care the signal
that you are never going to let go of
this pandemic
anthony fauci is uh is involved in in
this task because what he's about to say
here is completely anti-the science
are surgical masks good enough or should
everyone be wearing now n95s kn95s in
indoor venues
you know maybe instead of worrying about
what kind of mask just wear a mask wear
a mask you know wear a surgical mask a
cloth mask some people can't tolerate
n95s rather than saying one versus the
other we need to wear masks and the
delta variant has changed the playing
field it absolutely has it has a
extraordinary capability of spreading
from person to person and that's the why
the cdc is saying
even if you're fully vaccinated if
you're in an indoor
situation in an area of the country
which essentially is the whole country
with very few exceptions then you should
be wearing a mask when you're in an
indoor situation with other people not
in your home in a public situation
indoor because we're seeing breakthrough
infections you can get infected and have
no symptoms at all and then
inadvertently and innocently pass it on
to someone else who is not vaccinated or
is incapable of getting vaccinated
that's the reason for the cdc
recommendation about mass okay this is
super anti-scientific and what he's
saying at the end is not a scientific
question what he's saying at the end of
the public policy question so the notion
that all masks are equivalent is a bunch
of garbage media hassan is asking him
about that and fountain just ignores it
completely
hey the reality is blue surgical face
masks do nearly nothing according to a
study from the university of waterloo
the study shows n95 or canon 95s do the
best job of containing aerosol droplets
from the wearer's mouth but blue cloth
surgical masks which are popular because
they're more comfortable when i go out
in public and i have to wear a mask when
i was in la for example and they
mandated it
then i wore a blue surgical face mask
why specifically because it's
lightweight and specifically because it
is it is more comfortable than like a
kn95 for example how effective are they
they're 10
effective 10 percent which means
essentially ineffective
the study leader sergey rusevich a
professor of mechanical and mechatronics
engineering said quote there's no
question it's beneficial to wear any
face covering
however there's a very serious
difference in the effectiveness of
different masks when it comes to
controlling aerosols
okay and by the way that is that is
being done that study is being done by
mechanically shooting the virus at the
at the mask it is not being done how
people actually wear a mask which is you
put the mask on you take the mask off
you put the mask back on you spit all
over the mask it's wet you have more
aerosol droplets now exiting because the
mask is no longer dry
yeah yerasevich and his team said many
people wear masks that don't fit their
faces
this causes the aerosol droplets to
escape through multiple openings between
a person's face and the cloth mask which
could spread cover 19 in populous areas
by the way even the n95 was only able to
filter 50 percent of aerosol droplets
the other half is dispersed around the
wearer's head
yarosevich's team added that ventilation
test revealed even modest ventilation
rates provide about the same level of
protection as the highest quality masks
right so if you have like a hepa filter
and some open windows he's saying that
provides the same level of protection as
if everyone's wearing an n95
earlier this month of course michael
osterholm
said on cnn that cloth masks basically
don't do anything
and youtube tried to remove it because
how dare you
contra contradict the science which is
not even science
okay so you see you've got anthony
thought you reckon and then when anthony
fought you at the very end he says and
if you vaccinated and if you get it you
could pass it on to somebody who you
don't even know you don't and that
person is not vaccinated and you're like
well yes but they had the opportunity to
get vaccinated did they not
right that's like
isn't that on them
and then he's like and people couldn't
get that okay well if they can't get
vaccinated and they're peculiarly
vulnerable they should not be out in
public places in the first place or they
should be wearing an n95 or both
but there's no limiting principle the
idea is mask forever mask forever beyond
beyond point of death you had anthony
fouchy over here and he's like even
after you're dead you could pass it i
mean your body it's still it's still
giving off like the virus is still on
you what if somebody's handling your
body and it gets on the hands and then
they put it in the eyes
and then they get and they innocently
pass it on to a child
what if you die and we put you in the
grave and you don't wear a mask and now
a tree grows its roots into your grave
into your body and now the virus
explodes outward
into the tree
and it has fruit and the child picks the
fruit and eats the apple and the apple
has the covert what then
what if you chop down the tree and now
you're an old man and you're sitting
on the tree stump it's the giving tree
and you gotta and you're sitting there
and you think you're safe but you're not
cause you're old now it's been 80 years
since the tree grew from the grave of
the man with the covet and you're
sitting there innocently and up through
the ground through the tree stump into
your ass comes the covid
like that what are you talking about
there's no limiting principle it is all
about the politics i'm trying to cuddle
people to do things that do not make any
level of public policy sense every adult
in america has had the opportunity to
get the coveted vaccine if you do not
that is your problem now this is called
freedom they don't want the freedom the
freedom is the problem you see
when there's no limiting principle i was
willing to go along with this crap when
there was an end point at the very
beginning when we didn't know anything
go back and listen to my podcast at the
very beginning when we didn't know
anything i was like okay maybe we got to
lock down i mean we don't know how
unsafe this is it could be the bubonic
plague it could kill my parents it could
hurt my kids
and then over time we got more data and
then you respond to the more data that
is usually how the scientific process
works
and then you respond to even more data
that the vaccines are quite durable and
that natural infection has also created
an enormous number of people
who not only have antibodies but t-cell
immunity and one of the big problems
with some of the studies that are now
being done
on on the effects of the vaccine is that
they are attempting to measure antibody
levels antibody levels wane over time
for pretty much every vaccine the
question is not antibody levels the
question is t cell immunity which is
harder to measure so we've been using
studies that measure antibodies
even though the real question is whether
t cell it's like your memory cells
whether your t cells actually have
developed the immunity it is measured
differently so be like wow the
antibodies are waning that's scary that
means that we got to get another booster
or the vaccines aren't working no that's
not what that means at all your body
does not the antibody levels wane when
the virus isn't in the system the t cell
immunity remains
okay you got the mmr when you were a kid
right measles mumps and rubella you
don't have tremendous antibodies running
around your system for mmr because you
currently don't have measles mumps and
rubella in your system that your body is
attempting to fight off you have t cell
immunity
and by the way you've had boosters on
all of these like everybody who's saying
that boosters themselves are sort of a
an undercutting of the vaccine
when you're a kid you have boosters all
the time
and if you've had natural immunity
there's good evidence right now from
israel that natural immunity is actually
superior to the vaccine-induced immunity
if you have to choose between one and
the other for example but again
so much of the crisis mentality is
driven by the need for the political win
this is why you have joe biden
trying to yesterday say we need to mass
kids
hey the data on masking kids does not
exist it does not exist in fact there
are some pretty good counter data
here's joe biden saying again a thing
that is not scientific
let me say this as parents to the
parents
as you have you have the tools you have
the tools to keep your child safer
and two of those tools above all are
available to you
one make sure that everyone around your
child
who can be vaccinated
is vaccinated
parents adults teens
two
make sure your child is masked
when they leave home
that's how we can best keep our kids
safe make sure your child is masked when
they leave home
your kid is the safest person in the
room without being vaccinated your kid
is safer than you are okay you got
vaccinated and you're 40.
you are still less safe from kovid than
your kid who is unvaccinated by these
statistics your kid has a lower chance
of death if they are under 18 from kovid
than you do after being vaccinated and
he's like well you got to keep your kids
safe he's a liar he is lying to you okay
it is untrue that your kids are at vast
risk from covid
361 kids under the age of 18 have died
according to the cdc over the course of
the last year and a half
okay out of 73 million people in that
subpopulation
this drives me nuts
we'll get some more on this in just one
second because it's totally insane and
again it is politically driven first let
us talk about a thing that you could do
to improve your health get get more
sleep right that was a big one you got
to improve your health by getting more
sleep and there are a lot of reasons why
you can't get enough sleep but one of
the biggest reasons might be magnesium
deficiency you see magnesium is key it's
getting good sleep but 75 of people are
actually magnesium deficient is it any
wonder so many people have sleep
problems to help fix those sleep
problems and fully enjoy the calming
effects of magnesium you can check out
magnesium breakthrough by by optimizers
it is the only organic full spectrum
magnesium supplement that includes seven
unique forms of magnesium you can simply
take a couple of capsules before you go
to bed you'll be amazed by how much
better you sleep and how much more
rested you feel when you wake up
marie for example left a five star
review she says i'd give this 100 stars
if i could within one month of use i
went from daily struggles with restless
legs constipation and poor sleep to no
struggles with any of that i know it
sounds dramatic and far-fetched but it's
true for me magnesium breakthrough is
100 organic and made with vegetarian
non-gmo ingredients you can give it a
try and check out for yourself why many
people are raving about magnesium
breakthrough for an exclusive offer for
my listeners go to magbreakthrough.com
forward slash shapiro use shapiro 10
during checkout to save 10
alrighty so
again the the evidence on masking kids
does not exist this is not according to
me this is according to david zweig from
new york magazine quote the science of
masking kids at schools remains
uncertain
which is the reason why for example the
uk ireland scandinavia france the
netherlands switzerland and italy have
exempted all kids right under the age of
12 particularly from wearing masks in
classrooms
conspicuously there is no evidence of
more outbreaks in schools in those
countries relative to schools in the
united states
not only that the like we're just
cutting basically this is all politics
the cdc released guidance saying that
kids should wear masks and then the
american academy of pediatrics said
everyone in school over the age of two
should wear masks
and then the american academy of
pediatrics actually took down their own
guidance on why kids need to see faces
i'm not kidding
this is how much the science matters to
people in political positions
but as new york magazine says
there was a study it was put it was
published by the cdc and covered more
than 90 000 elementary school students
in 169 georgia schools from november
16th to december 11th
it was the first to compare covet 19
incidents in schools with certain
mitigation measures in place to other
schools without those measures
okay there was a provision in this study
that said there was no difference
between the schools that masked and the
schools that didn't
they didn't bother to actually publish
that finding instead they did what they
what is called file drawing they didn't
like the results so they just buried it
i mean which is insane by the way
okay they studied masking of kids it
made no difference they said masking of
staff might have made a difference which
makes sense because adults are getting
sick but
it made no difference with regard to
kids
and yet you have joe biden saying you
must ask your kids why is he doing that
why is he saying mask your kids he's not
just saying ask your kids by the way
and and let's also point out here that
it is completely inappropriate to
vaccinate kids under the age of 12 at
this point right this is the other point
that they make is they'll say well you
know you should you should mask the kids
because they can't vaccinate
well you can't vaccinate the kids right
that is obvious but then joe biden
didn't stop there he says i want vaccine
mandates from private companies now that
we've got fda approval i need your help
private america i need your help
business america to try and bully your
employees into getting the vaccine again
what is that what is the point of a
vaccine mandate really what is the what
is the point
if the idea is that all the people who
are unvaccinated are going to be forced
to be vaccinated
what's the goal of that is the goal to
protect them or is the goal to protect
others
if the goal is to protect them
then this is a free country and you get
to decide whether you want to be
protected against a given form of
disease
if the goal is to protect others
everyone else has had the same
opportunity to get vacs that you or i
have had period and yet here is joe
biden trying to use the power of
government to cuddle private industry to
do his work
today i'm calling on more country more
companies i should say in the private
sector
to step up with vaccine requirements
that'll reach millions more people
if you're a business leader
a non-profit leader
a state or local leaver who has been
waiting for full fda approval to require
vaccinations i call on you now to do
that require it
do what i did last month require your
employees to get vaccinated
or face strict requirements
okay so he's actively calling on people
to restrict other people in the united
states
and this is
rather authoritarian stuff
by the way it is worth noting here that
we were told that once you reached like
80 of people who were vaccinated in a
given society you would be on the verge
of herd immunity right herd immunity
apparently really does not apply to the
to the covet delta variant israel
reached 80 percent they're still locked
down
right they said that they were going to
return to normal apparently not
according to abc news in australia
life is set to be very different once 80
percent of australians are vaccinated
but one country has shown the dangers of
being too confident and throwing out the
rest of the coveted toolkit israel which
has a population only slightly larger
than
news in new south wales reopened
completely after reaching the 80 mark
and took a giant step backward israel
shot to an early lead in the race to
vaccinate inoculating its citizens at an
eye-watering pace to deliver the world's
fastest vaccine rollout around 78 of the
eligible population are now vaccinated
but in recent weeks israel has been hit
by a surprising resurgence of coven 19
with seven day average daily case
numbers surging past 6 500.
okay so bottom line is
if there is no return to normality based
on the percentages of people who are
vast then again no limiting principle no
return to normality ever
okay other things to point out here we
have been told that ron desantis and the
south are evil right if they'd only had
mass mandates this would have stopped
everything first of all we've seen a
massive surge in covet cases in
california which does have a lot of mass
mandates second of all as predicted on
this show repeatedly delta was going to
surge and then delta was going to recede
we knew this because that's exactly what
happened in the uk
and guess what
delta has now surged and delta has now
receded in the american south that's not
according to me that's according to
scott gottley but former fda
commissioner who's kind of a covet hawk
i thought there was an indication that
the the south was peaking and i think
it's very clear right now the south has
peaked i mean it doesn't feel that way
because we're still have we still have a
lot of new infections on a day over day
basis and the hospitals still have some
very hard weeks ahead they're going to
continue to get maxed out even after the
infections start to decline but there's
very clear evidence you look at states
like arkansas and louisiana you see the
cases coming down but if you look at
sites like covidestem.org the rt the
rate of expansion of this epidemic is
below one in most of the south
okay so that is good news is it not
you're not going to hear that from most
of the media the media is going to
continue to do the coveted panic routine
about the south
and then they're going to ignore the
fact that the reason that there has been
a covet spike in the south is because
it's very very hot outside and we're all
in crowded quarters right we're all
going indoors and so people who are
unvaccinated are getting are getting the
disease and then people who are
vaccinated some of them are getting
breakthrough cases which means generally
a mild flu or a mild cold i want to say
generally i mean except for very very
rare circumstances
so here's the question and it's a
question that nobody on the left has
been willing to answer so the left wants
the right to answer how many deaths are
you willing to take for freedom
and the answer on the right is some
right because this is true for virtually
all human activity
we all don't here's the thing human
beings don't tend to think about risk
level very often
we don't right if you thought about the
risk level of driving your car every day
and you were just every day in the media
if you get in your car you got a one in
one thousand chance of dying today
getting in your car if you thought about
that every single day you might not want
to get in your car maybe like i'm gonna
get an uber i'm gonna get on a bus right
but you don't think about it so it so in
your mind risk is binary there are
things that are risky and things that
are not risky it is not as though you
actually sit there and you calculate the
risks of all the things they're just the
things that are quote unquote risky and
the things that are quote unquote not
risky so for example skydiving you think
of this as a risky activity i think of
it as a risky activity the truth is
you're probably more like i think
significantly more likely to die in a
car accident than you are today
skydiving but one immediately goes to
i'm jumping out of a plane that sounds
riskier than getting behind the wheel of
a car so one is risky and one is not
risky in your mind driving around every
day is a risk factor of zero in reality
your risk factor driving around is
significantly higher depending on your
age bracket and certainly post
vaccination than your risk of dying from
covet
this is
just statistically the reality
post-vaccination there's no question you
are significantly more likely to die in
a car accident than you are to die from
covid 19 after you're vaccinated and you
see vaccinated people who have put
living normal life in the category of
very risky living without a mask in the
category of very risky
and so the question for those people is
okay so the question so when it comes to
freedom
we all recognize in in normal areas of
life sort of in the back of our mind we
recognize that there's a risk of death
to freedom right any time you go to a
ball game there could be a terrorist
attack any time you go out driving you
can get in a car accident anytime you
walk out your front door there's a risk
of something bad happening to you and we
all accept that as part of normal life
and so the question is how much risk are
you willing to accept in order to
continue normal life and the answer is
post vaccination you should be living
your normal life
post vaccination you get
we should all get back to living our
normal life post vaccination because
there is no alternative but to do so
okay otherwise
these are your choices get back to
normal life post vaccination or spend
the rest of your life masking and
waiting for the government to tell you
what to do
that is those are your choices for the
left there's no limiting principle for
people who have become coveted crazy
there is no limiting principle to this
for them i ask a question
what level of freedom are you willing to
give up to prevent
very small numbers of death
what level of freedom
in australia the answer is all of it
okay this should scare everybody in the
west in australia the answer is
literally all the freedom
australia is a country of some 25
million people
the the australian covet death rates
deontay are like three
kova
australia has been having
about three deaths a day from coven
they are having
800 900 cases of delta because it turns
out you cannot just shield yourself
behind fortress ocean forever which is
what australia tried to do for a year
australia basically made it that you
could not travel into australia
they basically tried to have a plague
city right they were just going to cut
off all outside contacts with the
outside world and then one person
entered with delta and now they have an
explosion in new cases
they bought by the way they did not
bother to get everybody vaccinated
because they were so confident in their
ability to shut out the outside world
that their vaccination rate in australia
remember america is terrible for our
vaccination right right we're the worst
we're just we're just awful it doesn't
matter that vast majority of adults in
the united states above the age of 18
like over 70 percent have had the
vaccine already in australia the number
of adults the percentage of adults who
have been vaccinated in australia is
about 25 about one quarter so they have
a huge unvaccinated vulnerable
population
so because of that australia has decided
they're going to crack down and when
they say they're going to crack down i
mean they are going to crack down so
here is a little bit of tape from nine
news in australia talking about the
measures they are taking this is full
authoritarian lockdown with no limiting
principle in sight
there's little sympathy for anyone
ignoring health orders even this group
of teenagers caught partying after dark
at the bottom of the north bondi cliffs
herded to higher ground by polar's
spotlight and speaker the eight boys
were placed in handcuffs and left to
explain a thousand dollar fine to mum
681 penalty infringement notices issued
in the last 24 hours more than 400 of
those notices were again for people
being outside of their home without a
reasonable excuse okay this is dystopian
insanity they've locked people in their
homes in a country of 25 million people
for three to four deaths a day
okay and they've locked them down
they're locking them down for weeks over
there
they outlawed protests by the way
in fact
we were told yesterday on the program by
a by a journalist from australia that
they have outlawed even saying things in
favor of protest in australia
because that would be promoting breaking
the law so what kind of tyranny are you
willing to undergo
in order to never get back to real life
and avoid all risk forever
and then you're going to have to ask
another question which is how much
pressure are you willing to bring on the
unvaccinated
in order to get them to vaccinate again
in order to protect their own lives
there's a story on msnbc that was making
the rounds yesterday
75 doctors claimed that they walked off
the job to protest the unvaccinated in
reality that's not really what was
happening
apparently what was actually happening
is they they exited the building to
encourage people to get vaccinated which
is fine right you wanna you wanna
encourage people to get vaccinated
that's fine msnbc covered it as though
these doctors were saying that they
would they did not want to care for the
unvaccinated
okay here is a little bit of the tape
from msnbc
as i step out here i can see they're all
standing here white jackets some coming
off of their ships your thoughts about
why it's gotten to this point that
people are gathered like this we feel
that people think it's political and
it's not it's medical i have all my
colleagues behind me and we're all here
as physicians to say one message
vaccines work it's safe it's not
political it's medical and we're very
passionate about it because we're
honestly tired of seeing unvaccinated
people come in sick and have to be
admitted okay so the way that the left
covered this is their suggestion was
that the doctors were refusing to care
for the unvaccinated and there was a lot
of talk in the media about how we should
be triaging in favor of the vaccinated
over the unvaccinated as opposed to
triaging based on who's most likely to
survive in a crisis scenario which is
usually how you triage right you
actually look at the health conditions
of the people underlying is it an 85
year old with with terminal cancer or is
it a 30 year old who is who's generally
healthy but has the disease and now can
be triaged
but the the
the attempt here
is to suggest that people don't deserve
medical care if they're unvaccinated now
i've said that if you're unvaccinated
that is on you but it is also true that
doctors care for everybody no matter how
they got sick right if somebody wheels a
person into the er who was shot in a in
a gang duel in a gang in a bout of gang
violence the doctors don't say well you
know they kind of brought on himself
they were in a sort of gang violence
scenario i guess i'm not caring for this
but that's not what doctors do if
somebody comes in and they're morbidly
obese and they've been told by their
doctor for literally their entire life
that they need to start eating healthy
and lose weight and now they have heart
disease the doctor isn't like well i did
tell you you shouldn't do that right
nobody that is not how medicine is
practiced
and i find it rather dystopian and scary
that there are people on the left who
are saying this sort of stuff people on
the left are saying this they're saying
if you're unvaccinated and you come into
the hospital the hospital shouldn't
treat you i'm amused to see however many
people on the left say things like if
you come into the hospital unvaccinated
you should be responsible for your own
medical bills that i'm in favor for i'm
in favor of that except not not with
regard to vaccination and not
vaccination i'm in favor of that for
everything we call that a privatized
medical health care system right in
which you are responsible for your own
health
okay but
again what this is really about is the
politicization i'm amazed to watch
people on the left say that the right is
politicizing this
no when you have dr fauci saying it
doesn't matter what mask you wear you
just need to mask up post vaccination
everywhere and when you have joe biden
saying you need to mask your kids every
time they leave the house when you have
joe biden saying your business should
tell people that they cannot work for
you if they are unvaccinated
who's making that political
and what's the real goal the real goal
of course is to distract from the giant
the reason we're doing that this week
right now the reason we've upped the
ante is not because the stats show that
we should up the ante this week as
opposed to like three or four weeks ago
the reason that we are doing this right
now is because joe biden needs to
redirect away from the gigantic failure
we are currently experiencing in
afghanistan and the crisis that is
likely to materialize over the course of
the next week we'll get to that in just
one moment first
it can be overwhelming to perform at
your best as you age yeah career family
staying in shape life can be stressful
you start to slow down you're not
present when you want to be to perform
at your best physically and mentally you
can't let age beat you this is where m
drive can help m drive is the daily
supplement for driven men who don't want
to slow down refuse to be tired every
day and want to be the best at what they
do it's packed with clinically tested
ingredients that support healthy
testosterone levels while helping you
lose weight and stay lean
add in vitamins and nutrients reduce
stress and boost your drive so you can
perform at your best find it at
walgreens and other retailers or visit
mdrive4men.com get 20 off your first
order with promo code ben
they have free shipping a 60-day
money-back guarantee so you've got
nothing to lose m drive it's not for
everyone it's for the driven give them a
try at m drive for men dot com promo
code ben that is the letter m drive for
men dot com promo code ben again you got
nothing to lose you get 20 off that
first order when you use promo code ben
and you've got the free shipping they've
got the 60 day money back guarantee so
you can give it a try and see if it
works for you
mdrive4men.com promo code ben alrighty
if you're looking for an alternative to
legacy media that actually values the
truth it's time for you to take a look
at the daily wire reader's pass okay the
reader's pass is four bucks a month
you'll unlock exclusive access to
editorial content you won't get anywhere
else and right now you get a free four
week trial when you sign up at
dailywire.com
subscribe but hurry this deal isn't
going to last much longer you'll find
trending political and cultural topics
penned by everyone from me to candace
owens to dan crenshaw you'll find
in-depth analysis pieces that always
offer a fresh perspective or you can
check out our reader's past collections
different series of articles on a given
subject current collections include
culture and crisis and blm the
organization behind a movement when you
sign up with readers pass you also get
access to the morning wire newsletter a
monday through saturday email covering
the top stories you need to know
available only to daily wire members all
of this can be yours for just four bucks
a month and act fast to get your free
four week trial at dailywire.com
subscribe that's a great deal and it's
never been a better time to take it so
what exactly are you waiting for get
informed get a reader's pass today
also if you are one of the people who
watches the matt walsh show you might
have heard the so-called sweet baby gang
is in need of a sweet baby anthem this
is your last chance to submit yours matt
is looking for an original song that
embodies the exact essence of the sweet
baby gang all submissions should be in
the form of youtube video links and will
be judged american idol style by me and
other daily wire hosts by you the viewer
will be voting on which song wins to
enter go to dailywire.com
sbg submissions end tomorrow august 25th
so if you think you've got what it takes
to impress matt your time is running out
voting will take place on labor day tune
in to the matt walsh youtube channel to
watch the judging of the submissions the
winner will be announced september 8th
on the matt wall show and will wear the
crown of the creator of the most
important anthem to ever be anthemed
again this is your last chance so
remember to enter your song into the
competition go to dailywire.com sbg we
all look forward to hearing it well some
of us do anyway you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so what is this really about right now
why is joe biden doing this right now
why is anthony fauci up in the game
right now and the answer is because this
failure in afghanistan is truly
horrifying so adam chef you never
experience expect to hear a true thing
out of adam schiff who again has a pup
tent it is it is placed right outside of
the msnbc green room he spent four years
lying about how there is going to be
inevitable evidence that donald trump
was a russian cat's paw
right you remember this okay but adam
schiff who can always be counted on to
back whatever is the democratic talking
point of the moment
he uh he did not when it came to
afghanistan yesterday it was very
unfortunate for the biden administration
according
to
the hill
house intelligence committee chairman
adam schiff said it was very unlikely
the us will complete its evacuation of
afghanistan by the august 31st deadline
he said quote i think it's possible but
i think it's very unlikely given the
number of americans who still need to be
evacuated it's hard for me to imagine
that all of that can be accomplished
between now and the end of the month
i'm encouraged to see the numbers of
people evacuating increasing readily to
the point where we evacuated 11 000
people in a single day nonetheless given
the logistical difficulties of moving
people to the airport and limited number
of workarounds it's hard for me to see
that could be fully complete by the end
of the month
he said i'm certainly of the view we
maintain a military presence for as long
as is necessary
to get all us persons out and to meet
our moral and ethical obligations to our
afghan partners so schiff admitted that
there are people who are stranded he
admitted that getting people out by
august 31st is unlikely
he said he is concerned about the
security of the airport he said i think
the threat to the airport is very real
and very substantial and he says this
makes an attractive target for isis it
does it is one runway and the gates are
not properly guarded and the people who
stand between isis and the americans
are um the taliban
and finally schiff admitted that the
intel community knew from the beginning
that the afghan government was likely to
collapse if the united states pulled out
and the taliban was likely to take over
which means that joe biden was just
lying that he was just lying
[Music]
intel committee member jason crowe
another democrat said i do not believe
at this point that i have any evidence
of an intelligence failure
so um then it's just
then it's just joe biden's fault which
is why he has to distract
so jen saki yesterday just gave an
astonishing statement
she was asked by peter ducey about the
americans currently stranded in kabul
her answer was to play semantic games
over whether they are actually stranded
or not
um i'm pretty sure that the americans
who are now being relegated to their
apartment
in kabul and are deathly afraid of
walking out the front door for fear they
will be beaten by the taliban and
there's nobody coming to get them they
probably feel a little stranded a little
by the way every major
news outlet in the united states has
called them stranded because they are
here's jen saki denying it does the
president have a sense that most of the
criticism is not of leaving afghanistan
it's the way that he has ordered it to
happen
by pulling the troops before getting
these americans who are now stranded
does he have a sense of that first of
all i think it's irresponsible to say
americans are stranded they are not we
are committed to bringing americans who
want to come home home we are in touch
with them via phone via text via email
via any way that we can possibly reach
americans to get them home if they want
to return home there are no americans
stranded is the white house's official
position on what's happening in
afghanistan i'm just calling you out for
saying that we are stranding americans
in afghanistan when i set when we have
been very clear that we are not leaving
americans who want to return home okay
no now she's shifting the conversation
right he's saying they are currently
stranded and she's like they're not
stranded he's like is that your position
it's like no i'm just i'm just saying
that we're gonna go get them because
it's like saying there were not men
stranded on the beach at dunkirk
okay they were and then people went and
got them they're americans currently
stranded in kabul the question is are
you going to go out there and are you
going to save them well one of the
questions that needs to be answered
before you even get to that is how many
americans are there even in kabul well
the good news is the american government
has no damned idea
in fact the american government is not
even willing at this point to say how
many americans they've gotten out
they're giving you broad numbers as to
how many people they've gotten out
a huge majority of those are afghan
nationals who worked with the united
states which is fine
but
they are not willing to say how many
americans are among that group
why well there's only one reason for
that in terms of public relations the
only reason for that is because the
number is kind of low here is uh here's
major general hank taylor admitting he
doesn't know how many americans have
even left
you'd mentioned that 42 000 have been
evacuated since july
uh is that 42 000 just on military
airlift or does that include the
commercial and chartered planes yeah so
that that total number is uh u.s
military plus u.s
uh civilian state department some of
that was state department uh contract
there that went out also earlier you
have any breakdown of the number of u.s
citizens in that 42 000 that have gotten
out um i do but i don't have that right
now uh well they don't have that and
then john kirby of the pentagon said the
same thing he's asked how many americans
have actually been evacuated well we
don't know or we're not going to tell
you what to do
that's the most important number here in
the number of americans
so if it's just a matter of checking the
number
can you do that and give it to us or if
you're being deliberately vague don't
tell me
why you're being deliberately big i
think i'm just going to leave it at
several thousand right now dave well
then tell us why
because i think uh the number is very
fluid um and it literally changes nearly
by the hour it's not more fluid than
than these eleven thousand and thirty
seven i'm gonna leave it several
thousand right now oh my god
that's unbelievable that's unbelievable
and that is from the spokesperson for
the pentagon so uh things are things
must be going great if they won't even
tell you how many americans they've
actually gotten out at this point things
must be going just spectacularly
meanwhile the taliban has set a red line
the taliban has said openly that if you
stay beyond august 31st then bleep gets
real here's a taliban spokesperson
saying this yesterday to sky news
if the u.s or the uk
wanted to extend the 31st
of august deadline in order to
continue evacuations out of the country
would you agree to that no no why not
th this is uh something uh you can say
it's a red line while there is no need
for for that i think that it will
deteriorate the relation that will uh
create mistrust between us if they
are intent on continuing the occupation
so it will um
provoke reaction and the bleep is about
to hit the pan because we're not getting
everybody out by august 31st and the
taliban have said that's the deadline
so what is joe biden willing to risk
here to get americans out we're about to
find out in very short the military says
has one week to decide to extend the
deadline and that's it
and past that they don't know what they
can do
all right we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of the ben
shapiro show coming up soon is the matte
wall show it airs at 1 30 pm eastern be
sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike caromina her
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show